هذا وتفقد ممثلون عن الامم المتحده مدينه
جنديرس شمالي سوريا لتقييم المساعدات
الاغاثيه بعد الزلزال وتوصف البلده بانها
من اكثر المناطق تضررا في الشمال السوري
وكانت المنظمه الدوليه قد ناشدت دول
العالم جمع 400 مليون دولار من الهبات
والتبرعات
للمنكوبين في سوريا
وقالت سنجانا كازي وهي مسؤوله بمكتب تنسيق
الاغاثه الامميه في سوريا قالت انها جوله
ممثلي عدد من المنظمات الاغاثيه في الشمال
الغربي من سوريا منسقه وتهدف الى تقديم كل
عونا ممكنا لضحايا زلزل
نحن هنا لتقديم يد العون والاستماع لتحديد
الاحتياجات وفعل كل ما في وسعنا في هذا
الصدد الوكالات التي تتفقد الشمال السوري
تنشط متظافره وننظر في افضل السبل لتوفير
كل ما يحتاجه المنكوبون